do you ever get anything wrong what do
you do I can make them is ie I get
everything wrong it's just that I can't
recall it because once it's wrong I'm
moving on to the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you [ __ ]
up on is the quickest way for the next
thing not to work right yeah so like so
I think I do everything I mean you know
this this is a fun thing to say some
people in the back know this I was a
breakout YouTube star in the first year
2006 I decided that the right strategy
was to leave YouTube completely and go
to viddler because viddler offered me
equity in their company and I've left an
enormous amount of attention I deviated
from my intention thesis to do
short-term economics and equity in a
company and I lost I lost Wendy Brock
finally came in my life two years ago we
started to try to build up my youtube
for the first time I was sitting on
40,000 user followers in a world where I
could have had millions if I just stayed
the course so I make mistakes all the
time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
[ __ ] about my mistakes everybody else
cares about your mistakes if you're
worried about your own mistakes you've
already lost
[Music]